Bats are extremely agile flyers
During flight they morph their wings--
changing the shape of the bones and skin
during different parts of the wingbeat
Bats have more than 40 joints in their wings
In order to capture this agility in a robot,
researchers created Bat Bot based
on the most important joints in the bat wing
Bat Bot is a fully autonomous flying robot,
Weighing in at 93 grams
And its articulated wings are covered
in an ultrathin, 56-micron membrane
It also moves its legs
in order to shape the wing surface
With this design, Bat Bot is able to fly straight,
dive,
and even make banking turns
Not only is Bat Bot a new
more agile type of aerial robot--
its design may give insight into how real
bats use their legs  to control pitch during flight.